well just a little bit off topic of what
i was planning on discussing today but
you just mentioned you got out of a
discussion with dieter um
there's always been a lot going on with
theater since the beginning of the
pandemic uh talk about
the budget discussions that you just had
and just broadly speaking
your um impression of how that
department has handled the
all of the unemployment claims all of
the issues that have happened since the
pandemic began you know a year ago
clearly the department was not prepared
to handle the influx of
of applications that it received for
unemployment benefits
when the economy got shut down and
that's not particularly its fault
right i mean no one really saw this
coming so it has been a long process to
to right the ship i think we're getting
there
uh we heard an amendment proposed to
their budget today which would allow for
the
hiring of another 200 positions over the
first year of the next biennium starting
july 1st so that they can i think get
everything in order
um you know they need a significant
technology upgrade that we need to fund
um and you know i think overall they're
on a good pathway right now i think
there's there's good leadership there
that
is trying to get things correctly
but it's it you know we know that it's
been a significant struggle for a lot of
our constituents
it's been painful to watch i i'm
remembering
i mean the the committee hearings kind
of blend together but i do remember an
interim
finance committee hearing some time over
the summer i seem to recall a sentiment
carlton and so forth
running the discussion and the
impression i got from everybody on both
sides of the aisle was just
and this is before some of the turnover
at the top the the
the lack of communication
the lack of some transparency from the
department
and as you mentioned the frustration
from your constituents
has any of that improved since the
summer
i think it has i think that um you know
maybe it's due to uh
precipitation and applications but
i do hear fewer complaints from
constituents
that they're unable to get through
they're unable to process
their applications or their
adjudications
we know there's still a backlog and
there's still a wait list in terms of
getting some
some problems resolved but i get the
sense
that things are on the upswing when it
comes to
communications from from the department
to
constituents now we've proposed a bill
to actually create
a a special office within dieter to be a
consumer advocate
the senate republicans have proposed
something like that um and i think
that's probably something we need to
look at going forward to ensure that the
voice of
um you know the the applicants and the
people that are supposed to be served
can be heard
more effectively so we'll see where that
gets
and you're just got out of this budget
discussion um
is this something that can be solved by
just throwing more money in it
or is there other issues that and you
mentioned technology but are there other
sort of functional things within dieter
that you believe need to be addressed
yeah i i do believe there needs to be
this um this sort of person-focused
office
uh within the department that looks uh
more specifically at the needs
of of our constituents and how they're
being
sort of responded to we also propose
putting some deadlines in
for um for responding to applications
and
and having eligibility determinations
made more quickly and more efficiently
so that people know what is coming to
them and what's owed to them so
i think that there are some things that
we can put in place that will
put a little bit more of a feed to the
fire so to speak of
of of dieter in terms of getting the
getting the work done
um but they also need the tools to get
the work done and that's going to
include some investment that's that's
financial
not just um not just legal consequences
right so
um that you know there's a technology
system upgrade uh to make sure that
our multiple systems talk to each other
you know we've got this pandemic
unemployment system and
our traditional unemployment system they
weren't connected people could be
eligible for both
so there were a lot of complicating
factors that led to sort of the perfect
storm
and i think that we just need to focus
on that going forward
in terms of how we can make it better
for people that should be our goal
sort of like when you're talking about
representing the people like an
ombudsman almost someone who is
advocating on behalf of the public
within the department itself
yeah it's based on an ombudsman's
program we're not calling it that
we're calling it right now but it is it
creates a position specifically within
dieter to be the voice of the people
um rather than the voice of the
government so hopefully they get some
traction
let's switch gears a little bit um i am
personally i'm quite interested in
esports
um i it's obviously a growing industry
uh especially down here in las vegas you
propose some legislation with regards to
kind of keeping an eye on speaking of
sort of ombudsman i suppose a commission
of sorts
why does esports need regulation in
nevada
so i'm coming to this clearly and
very very focused as an economic
development bill
right so i think that esports as
the fastest growing segment of the
entertainment industry and sports
industry
is uniquely positioned to fit um
perfectly with las vegas
to create additional tourism
additional technology ecosystem and
additional remote work so those are sort
of three lanes of an economic
development platform that we've
we've agreed to um at the highest levels
of the state from the governor on down
and esports fits all of those lanes
perfectly
so what this bill is modeled on is a
nevada athletic commission type of body
right
the athletic commission sanctions
unarmed combat boxing mixed martial arts
and if you look at the partnership that
the state was able to create with
ufc specifically but mixed martial arts
generally and the nevada athletic
commission
you know we became a hub for mixed
martial arts contests and
the corporate headquarters for ufc and
and all of those sorts of things
that have had a significant economic
impact on our state and so
esports uh is a sort of decentralized
um entity right there's no uh primary
sanctioning body
and you know this is a commission that
would provide
some oversight and integrity of
competitions that are happening in the
state
to ensure that there's confidence in
the ecosystem as a whole and in doing so
um i think that we can provide value to
all the different
pieces of this ecosystem to bring them
to our state to
host events here and grow companies here
is there a concern
i would imagine there's a big difference
between you know the nevada athletic
commission regulating
a boxing event at you know t-mobile
arena or whatever it is
versus a bunch of uh you know esports
players playing uh call of duty
or some you know a big contest a big
video game contest as you mentioned
decentralized online
uh what are they what are they going to
regulate
is it is it the human component is its
technical component what what can a
commission actually do
when the actual event while maybe taking
place in las vegas
it's kind of everywhere right so well
there are there are both online
tournaments and in-person events right
and
you need to start by looking at those
in-person events because something
that's held totally online we would
really have no jurisdiction over right
so
there has to be a nexus for us to have
some oversight for it so i think
you know the effort uh is to create a
partnership between
the state and this and the nevada
esports commission and industry to
both identify issues that would be more
appropriate for a commission to
to oversee um as well as
get those implemented so those could be
things like setting up standards
for competition and developing those so
that they're applied uniformly across
different different types of
competitions it could be enforcement of
things like team roster changes or
something to that effect so that
um you know people people know what's uh
what's to be expected for
for those levels of competition you know
the bill specifically calls out
um drug testing potentially is something
that uh the commission could oversee
so the idea is to create a system of
integrity around
um around esports generally that would
allow
for consumer and player confidence and i
think that leads to
growth of the industry long term for for
everybody
a rising tide floats all boats let's a
little more on technology uh
you and i not you and i but you have
talked before about uh the uh the
sandbox as it were
um issues of bitcoin issues of
innovation there's a lot of other
technological
industry things being discussed up at
carson city right now
looking ahead to the future whether it's
in northern or southern nevada
what are you most focused on right now
what
legislation are you specifically hoping
will
maybe uh make sure nevada's foundation
has a foundation
for the future beyond resorts beyond
gambling beyond mining etc
yeah sure i i think you know we talk a
lot about economic diversification and
technology continues to play
a key role in all of those discussions
and that's why um
you know the building you mentioned
previously esports i think is is
important because when you talk about
technology it's a really broad topic
right and it can mean a lot of different
things to a lot of different people so
finding sort of those niche areas where
we can focus our efforts is incredibly
helpful we did that starting
back in 2017 with legislation
surrounding blockchain
and creating some statutory framework
for blockchain operations in our state
and it's been incredibly successful to
attract
companies using the blockchain and their
technology applications
to nevada there's been hundreds of
millions of dollars invested thousands
of jobs created
and this was all done just by creating a
statutory framework no incentives no
you know nothing like that this was just
creating good public policy
that attracted business to the state and
i think we can do the same
when it comes to esports through a um
by creating a good technology base right
it's it's a niche that falls directly in
line with our focus on professional
sports and the growth of
you know the nfl the nhl um you know
wnba
ever everyone that's operating in las
vegas right now um
has a direct alignment often with
esports competitions and esports teams
leagues so um sort of focusing on that
technology component of what we're
already
good at is a really good way for us to
try to create some of that
diversification
just to again one finally touch on um
cryptocurrency blockchain which is
obviously those are unified in in many
respects
um the innovation zone that governor
sisilak mentioned for up in northern
nevada which is
its own sort of situation there
what would you like to see take place
sort of continue what you're talking
about when it comes to the
this foundation for especially something
like cryptocurrency blockchain which is
very advanced
stuff for a lot of our viewers but is
also very important
so i think one of the most powerful
things that the government can do
to encourage growth within the
technology sector
is to become adopters right and that's
for us to use the technology that we
want to see
happen in our state so state treasurer
has proposed a bill
for the state to start accepting stable
coin potentially as a
as a system of payment i think that if
we want to see growth within the
within the financial technology space uh
cryptocurrency and in that area
that it makes sense for us to start
bringing that within our own house
um and accepting those as forms of
payment um so that's one example
another is that the state needs to start
doing more um
electronic records collection and usage
so that we can
sort of move away from paper and start
recognizing and using the technologies
that businesses are using on a daily
basis
we don't need to be nearly as paper
focused as we are right now
so i think government adoption is one
thing that we need to continue to focus
on i sponsored some legislation about
that a couple years ago we probably need
to strengthen it
um to ensure that as we move forward um
we
were doing what we preach finally and
not connected to technology at all
there's a couple other bills but i
wanted to just quickly ask about
um senate bill 121 about primary
elections
okay i gotta i gotta check my list to
make sure i know i know
monday was a busy day for everybody i
know right
there's been a lot of lawmakers and a
lot of you know the secretary of state's
office there's been a lot of discussion
about
what happened with the last election the
primary and the general election
with the coronavirus and and how
the changes that were made to ensure
safety and so forth
um back then the secretary of state's
office suggested that this was going to
be the only time we did like the only
mail-in balloting that was sort of the
general
thought there what do you think
or what are you proposing with regards
to primary elections moving forward
what that we experience during the
coronavirus
should stick around moving forward and
what are you concerned about
yeah so you know elections are getting a
lot of discussion up here at the
legislature this session
um they're there everywhere on election
issues
so i think it's important to recognize
what some of the big changes are that
we're making
during the special session we
we approved all mail balloting and it
was used in both the
uh primary and general election um but
that was
pegged to the coronavirus pandemic there
are proposals to amend that to
make that permanent so that uh so that
there's universal mailing
mail in balloting during all all
upcoming elections so we need to
think about what what those big changes
are
and how we can align our other laws so
that they match
whether if we're going to move to an
all-male ballot system we should talk
about
those ballots are secure so i think that
that includes things like signature
verification
making sure that our voter rolls are as
clean as possible to
make sure we're not mailing out ballots
to people who may have moved and are no
longer residents who may have passed
away
and i think those are some of the
discussions that we're having now i
think we also need to look at
the changing reality of our electorate
and not just our election system
i've proposed in senate bill 121
recognizing the fact that more than a
third
or more than 30 percent of the voters in
the state of nevada have decided not to
be a member of the republican or
democratic parties
and primaries most often decide
elections
i think we know that we've seen that and
for the fact that
um our closed primary system doesn't
allow nonpartisans and minor party
members to participate
in the most important election of the
cycle they effectively get shut out of
represent
of choosing who represents them in their
government so i'm proposing an
open primary system it's a blanket
primary that allows
all voters to participate in primary
elections and it really changes how we
have to think about
our primaries we're no longer having a
primary that chooses a democratic
candidate and chooses a republican
candidate
we have all voters choose
to to choose who they want to go through
to the general election all candidates
go on one ballot
all voters get to vote the top two go
through to the general election and the
winner takes all
i think that's a system that recognizes
the fact that people are turning away
from the two major political parties
and it would give a stronger voice
to more people in this state to elect
their representatives in government
and hopefully bring us more together
rather than pushing us apart because the
system we have now
pushes us to the fringe rather than
rather brings us back to us
i could talk for a long time but we had
a long legislative session so we'll talk
about some other stuff later
i appreciate the time